peu
[Musique]
la télévision est la plus grande
victoire de l'image les maisons du monde
entier se sont couvertes d'antenne elles
seront bientôt 200 millions c'est anthem
semblant surgir des toits soul ondes qui
désert aux l'image
[Musique]
oh
l'image de l'événement immédiate des
fidèles ou presque puisqu'il leur
manquait ce facteur de vérité
essentielle la couleur
le monde vivant est en couleur et son
image ne peut être condamné au noir et
blanc mais pour diffuser aujourd'hui une
image en couleur il faut penser aux
centaines de millions de téléspectateurs
qui ne peuvent recevoir qu'en noir et
blanc et qu'il serait injuste de
sacrifier ainsi le programme en couleurs
telles que le reçoit l'eau
téléspectateurs munis d'un téléviseur
couleur le téléspectateur classique
équipé du noir et blanc doit pouvoir le
capter c'est la première compatibilité
imposé à la télévision en couleurs
quand le programme n'est transmis corps
noir et blanc on ne peut obliger le
téléspectateur muni du téléviseur
couleur d'allumer un téléviseur noir et
blanc classique pour le recevoir
il faut donc que le téléviseur couleur
reçoivent aussi le noir et blanc c'est
la deuxième compatibilité la télévision
en couleurs soumises à ces impératifs va
se servir des méthodes du noir et blanc
comment fallait il faire pour sauver
pour prévenir la le tube analyseur de la
caméra traduit d'abord l'image formé sur
la cible photoélectrique en une réplique
de la scène visée cette réplique formé
de charge électrique correspond point
par point à l'intensité lumineuse de la
scène et c'est point par point qu'elle
va être démontée par le faisceau
d'électrons analyseur recueillant
successivement les charges électriques
comme si le démonter un mur brique par
brique al'allure record il est vrai de 6
millions de briques par seconde ainsi se
forment le signal vidéo donnant à chaque
instant les valeurs lumineuse d'un point
d'image quand il est transmis par radio
c'est la télévision
pour reconstruire l'image de la rizerie
chaque ligne de points est étiqueté par
une pulsion repères de ligne qui
synchronise le balayage du tube
cathodique de réception où l'image se
reconstitue toujours quand en plus grand
sera le nombre de points par ligne plus
film sera l'image c'est la définition
horizontale
le nombre de lignes de balayage 625 par
exemple caractérise la définition
verticale de l'image la télévision est
au service de l'humain qui s'accommode
admirablement de ces procédés il
fusionne tous les points en une image
unique
comme au cinéma la succession rapide
d'image du mobile lui donne l'impression
du mouvement une bonne nouvelle pour les
automobilistes mais c'est être humain
est en couleur lui aussi
les coloris mais triste savent depuis
longtemps analyser la structure des
couleurs et le physicien max ouais on a
décrit les lois de façon intuitive avec
son triangle découverts chaque point de
couleur située à l'intérieur de ce
triangle née d'une addition à doses
variables des couleurs primaires rouge
bleu vert au centre du triangle un
mélange additifs ados égal de rouge de
bleu et de vert donne le blanc de
référence la position d'un point par
rapport au sommet du triangle figure la
dose des primaires ainsi un point
turquoise comporte beaucoup de bleu
[Musique]
presqu'autant de verre est très peu de
rouge un point jaune sera produit par du
bouge pas mal de revers et du bleu à
très faible dose
[Musique]
ces primaires constitutive a plus ou
moins hautes doses peuvent engendrer un
signal électrique proportionnelle dans
trois caméras qui seraient spécialisées
chacune dans une telle primaire la rouge
la bleue et la verte l'ensemble des
trois signaux électriques définissent
conjointement le point de couleur si ce
point de couleur se déplace dans le
triangle les signaux électriques vous
variez non pas indépendamment l'un de
l'autre mais suivant la loi même de la
trichromie la conservation des écarts
entre les trois signaux est donc
essentiel pour la reproduction des
couleurs pour transmettre les images en
couleur
la première idée consiste ainsi à
braquer sur la scène à télévisée trois
caméras identique chacune muni de son
filtre le rouge le bleu et le vert
chaque caméra analyse alors à pleine
définition les images existant dans les
trois couleurs primaires traités comme
des images indépendantes chacune ayant
sa brillance propre les signaux vidéo
ignorent qu'ils correspondent à une
couleur particulière
ils peuvent attaquer trois tubes
récepteur qui projette l'image coloré
fidèles obtenus par synthèse additive
[Musique]
la de procédés de réception encombrants
est délicat mais en fait valable que
pour de grands écrans professionnels et
n'a pas sa place dans le récepteur
individuelles qui exige un tube unique
le col de ce tube unique comporte trois
canons électrons dont chacun sera mis au
service d'une couleur il n'était
évidemment pas question de superposer
simplement les écrans colorées ses
écrans ont alors été fragmentée en de
multiples points colorés verts bleus
rouges juxtaposée à l'intérieur du tube
sur sa face interne
ces points colorés son décor
luminescents réagissant dans leur
couleur spécifique aux chocs des
électrons on les appelle des phosphores
ils sont groupés en bouquet de 3 et
l'écran en comporte près d'un demi
million à distance normal ces points se
font ensemble pour donner une impression
continue quand l'excitation des trois
phosphore du bouquet est égal cette
impression est celle du blanc quand les
canons vert et bleu sont et à la plage
et rouge ou verte
si les canons rouge et bleu sont coupées
pour assurer cette excitation sélective
par les canons les inventeurs américains
de ce tube universellement adopté on a
généreusement disposer un masque perforé
entre les canons et les camps masque
perforait d'autant de trous qu'il ya
deux bouquets ainsi le canon affecté au
rouge le pour attirer ces électrons à
travers le tout en faisant mouche sur le
phosphore rouge
de même pour le bleu et le vert
[Musique]
l'image est reconstituée en permanence
par le balayage des bouquets ligne après
nous la dose exacte d'excitation des
phosphores est réglé à tout instant par
le signal primaire qui commandent
l'intensité du feu d'électrons de chaque
canon dans sa couleur
en fait ces canons sont constitués d'une
cathode émettant les électrons et
d'organes de contrôle les vénètes
interposés sur leur trajet c'était même
ce faisant office de ram modère le débit
des électrons suivant le signal
électrique quand le rapliq
tel est le tube prix canon à masquer qui
reconstitue l'image cool r mais comment
assurer la compatibilité à partir de
l'un des signaux électriques primaire
aucun ne convient en réalité pour former
l'image noir et blanc sur un tube
classique monochrome
on ne rendrai parfaitement compte de
l'intensité lumineuse du sujet ni par le
signal rouge ni par le bleu ni par le
vert il faut autre chose il faut
l'information de luminance quand le flux
de lumière est important leblanc et
brillant quand ils diminuent les
couleurs s'assombrissent le blanc
rejoint le noir en passant par la gamme
des gris un point de couleur subissant
ces variations sera paris les signaux
électriques mais ils varieront tous les
trois proportionnellement aux
changements d'intensité
lumineuse il existe donc un signal
commun aux trois caméras ce signal
commun va pouvoir être 10 juin des
signaux primaire propres à chacune des
caméras il définit l'intensité lumineuse
de la scène colorée et portait six ans
lui une information de toute première
importance
l'information de luminance qui a
plusieurs rôles à jouer à partir des
trois signaux primaire l'élaboration du
signal de luminance désigné par le
symbole y demande un peu d'arithmétique
la simple addition des trois primaires
seraient maladroite car la réponse de la
rétine au flux coloré et aime que c'est
la lumière dans le vert qui apporte au
cerveau l'impression subjective maximum
celle du rouge
une impression moyenne celle du bleu
enfin une impression faible le signal
électrique de luminance et donc mieux
donné par la somme pondérée de signaux
primaire dont les coefficients
traduisent les fait subjectif réel la
somme de ses coefficients est égal à
l'unité ce signal de luminance dès lors
parfaitement analogue au signal de la
télévision classique en noir et blanc
pourra très bien alimenter un récepteur
noir et blanc
[Musique]
voilà maintenant respecter la première
loi de compatibilité grâce à ce signal
de luminance élaboré à partir des signes
aux primaires mais à côté de ce premier
rôle
le signal de luminance y entier un autre
fondamental dans la transmission de
l'image en couleurs ce rôle est celui
d'un pilote d'un garde-fou qui applique
à chaque instant au récepteur la somme
des trois primaires ne pas dépasser pour
ne pas fausser par rapport à la scène
originale la quantité de lumière fournie
aux téléspectateurs
[Musique]
comptable qui veillent en permanence la
fidélité de l'addition le signal de
luminance va permettre de réaliser une
première économie puisque le signal de
luminance porte une dose connue de
chacun des signes aux primaires il
serait superflu de transmettre
simultanément récepteur les trois signes
aux primaires si on renonce à
transmettre le signal primaire verts par
exemple le récepteur ne recevra
naturellement aucune information directe
dans le cher en revanche si du signal de
luminance y il soustrait après les avoir
pondérer les signes rouge et bleu qu'il
reçoit en permanence le récepteur sera
reconstitué le signal vers manquant les
trois signaux primaires sont ainsi tous
obtenu est prêt à attaquer le tube
ce calcul électronique s'opère la
réception de façon continue dans une
matrice et le signal verseur en
permanence trois signaux celui de
luminance et ceux de couleur sont donc
transmis mais affecté trois émetteurs
distincts chacun serait parfaitement
impraticable l'espace radioélectrique
déjà forte encombrer la mettrait pas un
tel gaspillage de fréquences d'autres
économies sur le contenu des signaux
sont heureusement possible car l'oeil et
de connivence avec ingénieurs l'oeil
ignore en effet la couleur des détails
très faim dont il ne perçoit plus que
l'intensité lumineuse les nuances exacte
de ses trois fils bleus par exemple
n'apparaîtrait vraiment à l'oeil que sur
de grandes surfaces
or ce qui échappe à la vision naturelle
il serait vain de chercher à le
transmettre les détails très fin c'est
au signal de luminance élaboré à partir
des primaires à haute définition
fournies par les caméras qu'incombe
leurs transmissions les signaux
primaires seront donc soulagé de cette
mission d'information le signal de
luminance y est soustrait du signal
rouge et aussi du signal bleus opération
qui donne naissance à deux signaux dit
de chrominance la réduction de la
finesse d'analystes de la communance se
traduit par la possibilité de comprimés
à l'aide de filtres au départ la bande
de fréquence que tout signal emprunte au
spectre radioélectrique autour de sa
fréquence porteuse les lois de
l'information sont en effet inexorable
plus l'image est fouillé plus large et
la bande de fréquence que nécessite
cette transmission correct c'est le prix
à payer dans l'espace radioélectrique
avec sa haute définition
l'image de luminance s'est largement
servi par une transmission à large bande
l'image de chrominance se satisfait
d'une définition plus basse on se trouve
toujours à la tête de trois signaux
qu'il s'agit de transmettre sur un
émetteur unique
la technique téléphonique éprouvé des
fréquences sous-porteuse va résoudre ce
problème apparemment insoluble
grâce au fait que les deux signaux de
chrominance peuvent se transmettre avant
de ré duit articulé sur leur fréquence
porteuse
ces bandes réduite sont encastrées dans
la bande de grandes largeurs consacré à
la luminance à pleine définition
les fréquences porteuse de chrominance
seront regardés par la porte principale
comme partie intégrante du signal de
luminance d'où leur nom de sous porteuse
des filtrages soigner à l'arrivée comme
au départ empêcheront toute confusion
un peu comme les voies d'un coeur fondu
dans un ensemble vocal unique gardent
leur fréquence propre facilement
identifiables les soprani chante la
couleur l'ensemble le noir et blanc
dessous porteuses sont semble-t-il
nécessaire mais l'électronique qu'on
ferait encore des ressources et une
seule sous porteuse peut suffire au prix
il est vrai d'une double modulation
simultanée de cette unique sous porteuse
par les deux signaux de chrominance les
signaux complexe de la télévision en
couleurs rayonné par un seul émetteur
sont reçus ensemble par le récepteur
réglé sur la fréquence est mise à la
sortie les divers circuits
l'amplification filtrage détection le
signal de luminance et les deux signaux
de chrominance rouge et bleu se retrouve
à l'entrée d'une matrice qui fournira
les trois signaux primaire dont le vert
une simple addition de la communance
rouge et de la luminance à haute
définition restitue le signal-prix mer
rouge
de même pour le signal primaires bleu le
vert exige au préalable le calcul de la
chrominance verte à partir des trois
signaux reçus les additions de luminance
injecte en permanence une haute
définition aux primaires non plus celle
qu'il possédait en propre
maintenant perdu par compression mais
cette haute définition collective portée
par le signal de luminance ces
opérations peuvent être transféré en
grande partie dans les canons du tube
les signaux de chrominance rouge et bleu
sont envoyés directement sur les canes
ont affecté à leurs couleurs
la matrice se borne à élaborer le signal
de chrominance du verre celui qui n'est
pas transmis le seigneur de luminance
attaque les cathodes des trois canons
reliés ensemble les faisceaux
d'électrons suivre l'intensité du signal
de luminance tous ensemble avec la
pleine définition porté par celui ci le
signal de chrominance appliquée aux vnf
module le faisceau la résultante finale
et son intensité sont bien conformes
signal primaire
[Musique]
quand il n'y a pas de couleur du tout
dans l'image comme dans cette robe les
signaux de chrominance un nul ce qui
n'est pas leur moindre avantage pour le
vérifier encore un peu d'arithmétique
et même dans le chèvre le signal de
luminance seule commande les trois
faisceaux tous ensemble les trois
phosphore sont excités pareillement ils
reproduisent bien du gris
la réapparition de couleur au sein de
l'image déséquilibre ce tir égaliser en
ajoutant l'information de chrominance
l'image couleurs se nourrit de luminance
et de chrominance émir télévision
classique
ce bouquet deviendra gris le tube du
téléviseur couleur ne reçoit plus
maintenant qu'un signal vidéo classique
pour alimenter ces trois canons c'est la
deuxième combativité les indéniables
qualités de ces images ne doivent pas
masquer les difficultés et les risques
qu'il y à transmettre deux informations
aussi délicate que la couleur quand
elles se partagent la voix unique d'une
seule sous porteuse
la stabilité est essentielle il fallait
explorer d'autres solutions
le système proposé pour l'europe s'y est
attaché
ce système transmettent en un instant
donné un seul signal de chrominance par
exemple celui du bleu on voit qu'en
possession de cet unique signal bleus la
matrice ne pourrez calculer les deux
autres signaux de chrominance en rouge
et en verre elle ne connaît que leur
somme grâce au signal de luminance mais
à la réception
ce signal unique bleus est dédoublé en
deux jumeaux dont l'un se dirigera
directement vers la matrice tandis que
l'autre représenté au dessous renversera
un dispositif à retardement sortes de
handicaps qui lui fera subir un retard
d'une longueur soit le temps exact de
balayage d'une ligne à la prochaine
ligne on émettra un signal rouge qui à
la réception subira le même traitement
dédoublement puis dispositif en retard
pour l'un des jumeaux et ainsi de suite
bien sûr ce qu'on voit là au ralenti
avec des temps d'arrêt se déroule en
réalité de façon ininterrompue à la
cadence de plus de 15000 ligne à la
seconde
que se passe-t-il à chaque instant à la
sortie de cette double voie
à chaque instant un signal bleu et un
signal rouge sont présents mais alors
que le signal bleus n'ayant subi aucun
retard est bien celui de la ligne en
cours de transmission le signal rouge
est un signal retard d emprunter la
ligne précédente
ce sera l'un verse pour la ligne
suivante signal rouge normalement
transmis signal bleus emprunter la ligne
précédent il ne reste plus qu à
aiguiller tous les signaux de même
couleur vers l'entrée correspondante
c'est le rôle de l'inverseur
électronique automatiquement déclenchée
par les impulsions de balayage ainsi
ligne après ligne
le processus se répète et l'image se
reconstitue tel est le principe du
balayage alternée l'une des bases du
nouveau procédé du procédé proposé pour
l'europe le ccap
[Musique]
ce balayage alterné exploitant deux fois
sur deux lignes voisine une même
information de chrominance entraîne une
baisse de la définition verticale mais
cette définition verticale est toujours
très largement supérieur à ce que l'oeil
demande
ces réductions entame à peine la marge
énorme par rapport à la définition
horizontale transmise à bandes réduite
une image parfaite
et pourtant un seul signal de
chrominance à transmettre à la fois avec
cet atout techniques considérables
le système ccam a pu choisir pour l'ass
ou porteuses de comines ans et son
signal unique le meilleur procédé de
transmission la modulation de fréquence
celle de la haute fidélité en modulation
de fréquence londe supportant le signal
conserve une amplitude rigoureusement
constante le signal de la modifie pas la
fréquence de la sous porteuse
caractérise le blanc de référence
les fréquences qui s'en écartent
caractérise les autres points de couleur
les signaux primaire issus de la caméra
rouge par exemple module la fréquence de
référence suivant la dose de primaires
rouge un point se déplaçant vers le
turquoise correspondra à une
augmentation de fréquence une fréquence
supérieure la fréquence de référence
caractérise donc le turquoise
inversement en se déplaçant vers le
sommet rouge
la fréquence caractéristiques diminue en
passant par la fréquence de référence du
blanc ainsi la modulation de fréquence
rend elle compte de la position exacte
des points de couleur incluse dans sa
modulation de fréquence la chrominance
du secam est prête à affronter les
péripéties de la transmission
c'est un signal robuste il y a dans la
théorie de l'information une loi
physique qui tend à désorganiser tout
message à le noyer dans le bruit de fond
général du monde électro magnétiques qui
le traversent
comme dans ses ennemis plus proche que
sont les parasites industriels
mais la communance elle-même constituée
à un certain degré un signal parasites
pour l'image de luminance reçu par les
téléviseurs noir et blanc et c'est
encore la modulation de fréquence avec
son amplitude rigoureusement constante
bien en dessous de l'amplitude de
luminance qui offre la protection la
meilleure contre cet effet parasites
cette modulation apporte encore d'autres
avantages
les altérations que subit la phase
calage autant 02 tous phénomènes
vibratoires modifie le phénomène si
l'information est liée à la phase elle
en subira les fluctuations en modulation
fréquents
l'information est contenue dans le
nombre d'oscillations contée par le
récepteur donc l'information de tintin
dans le secam ne sera pas affectée
normalement par les altérations de
phases qualités fondamentales qui permet
au signal de franchir correctement les
longues lignes de transmission des
relais aux émetteurs en passant par les
faisceaux hertziens
au studio même cette qualité permettent
aux ccam d'enregistrer ces signaux sur
les magnétoscopes classique du noir et
blanc nouvel avantage au moment où
l'enregistrement magnétique des
programmes de télévision s'affirme comme
l'un des meilleurs outils des
réalisateurs en bout de chaîne le
téléspectateur est le grand bénéficiaire
de toutes ces améliorations il ne
trouvera pas sur son téléviseur couleur
davantage de boutons à régler que sur le
téléviseur noir et blanc la teinte
transmises rigoureusement par la
modulation fréquence n'a pas à être
réajusté l'image l'image en couleurs
émergents de signaux fidèles et stable
apportera l'authenticité du monde réel
ce monde est en couleurs et son image ne
pouvait vraiment pas être condamné au
noir et blanc
dc cam avait causé des télévisions
couleurs en 1956 j'ai donc eu la chance
de le trouver une idée originale ce qui
n'arrive pas très fréquemment des
douanes est chouette idée originale the
gas l'idée d'une idée générale souhaite
de ces deux c'est qu'au lieu de
s'acharner à transmettre simultanément
trois formations ont pouvons transmettre
deux le principe de la télévision tout
le monde le connaît la caméra de prises
de vues de télévision classique permet
la transformation d'une image optique en
un signal électrique aisé à transmettre
un pinceau électronique décompose
l'image en ligne et sur chaque ligne
mesure la charge de chaque point d'image
le signal électrique ainsi formé peut
être émis par radio etc la télévision
telle que nous la connaissons
à la réception l'image se reconstituent
ainsi sur l'écran du téléviseur
point par point ligne parler et pour
reproduire des images en couleur
il faut que l'écran du téléviseur porte
des éléments phosphorescent coloré
frappé par un rayon électronique des
éléments s'illuminant leurs couleurs
caractéristiques vertes rouges ou bleues
le tube images comprend trois sources
d'électrons respectivement modulée par
des signaux électriques caractéristiques
de la composante verte rouge et bleu de
l'image a reproduit tous ces petits
points se fonde pour former une image
continue ce qui fait l'intérêt de
l'invention dans vie de france et que
l'une des informations étaient mises en
permanence la luminance cependant que
les deux autres ou chrominance sont
émises alternativement sans risque de
mélange dans le récepteur les
informations de chrominance suivent un
double chemin un chemin direct et un
chemin avec un dispositif à retardement
ce qui permet d'éviter ainsi toute
déformation de couleurs et comment vous
est venue l'idée
vous savez c'est extrêmement difficile à
dire parce qu'on a d'abord une petite
idée
on expérimente et on modifie depuis ça
c'est le point de départ lors on se dit
bon bah ça c'est une bonne voie
[Musique]
porte de versailles salon international
de la radiotélévision le premier salon
de la couleur à trois semaines du
lancement officiel en france de la
télévision en couleurs
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce que vous
êtes séduits par la couleur ben ça
change ce nouveau mais c'est très joli
juste un mois j'étais venu espèces on
voit les faits mais je trouve ça
vraiment joli c'est une très jolie chose
je trouve que c'est évidemment je me
force à me paraît assez ne change pas
tellement noir et blanc on sait quand
même que c'est vrai je pense que ça a
certainement un très grand avenir et que
dans quelques temps de nous voir sa
troupe ont disparu les couleurs sont un
peu sur la première fois mais je trouve
que c'est bien ça nous paraît peut-être
un peu pas très net est très clair mais
je suis sûr qu on s'habituera version
merveilleux oui vous venez de l'entendre
tout ce qu'ils ont vu le constate la
couleur apporte au petit écran une
nouvelle dimension
[Musique]
trois procédés de télévision en couleurs
existe actuellement dans le monde
le ntsc américain le pal allemand et le
secam séquentiel à mémoire procédé
français choisis par de nombreux pays
dont l'union soviétique et les pays de
l'est procédé mis au point par henri de
france
sinon ile-de-france procédé français
ccam de télévision couleur c'est votre
enfant oui monsieur ne veut c c'est mon
enfant à l'origine mais bien entendu il
a fallu faire un développement intensif
et ce développement ne peut se faire
qu'avec des équipes d'ingénieurs de
grande valeur et de grande et bouble
quand et comment avez-vous inventé ce
procédé
eh bien vous savez dans le métier de
l'électronique auquel j'appartiens
depuis près de 40 ans j'ai pas vu de
cibler de révolution c'est à dire ça a
été constamment une évolution en
ensemble perfectionnement qui ajoutés
les uns aux autres finissent par faire
un produit et qui devient définitif
alors pour le secam ça a été aussi le
résultat d'études que nous avions déjà
fait pendant près de dix ans avant c'est
à dire que en ce qui me concerne et en
ce qui concerne beaucoup mes
collaborateurs ça fait 20 ans que nous
travaillons la couleur est ce que dans
l'avenir il n'y aura plus qu'un seul
procédé de télévision en couleur noire
et vous non je ne le pense pas mais il
faudrait pas croire que c'est grave le
spa on a écrit beaucoup et on a dit
beaucoup sur la question fait c'est
extrêmement facile les systèmes sont
très voisins système a le secam sont
très voisins nous avons résolus
complètement le système du transcodage
aucune difficulté pour les échanges de
programmes tous a été vérifié et le pose
aucun problème
d'autre part vous allez avoir des
récepteurs qui pour recevoir le palais
le secam
et même le téléspectateur ne s'en
apercevra même pas je parle de ceux qui
sont sur des régions frontières ne peut
recevoir l'un ou l'autre des systèmes ya
automatiquement le récepteur se mettra
en harmonie avec le système utilisé
monsieur de france comment envisagez
vous l'avenir de la télévision en
couleurs en france eh bien c'était une
question qui m'intéresse beaucoup et
évidemment moi je vois un très grand
avenir à la télévision en couleurs le
pensent eux que tout est en couleur
maintenant noces page le cinéma et le
mêle aussi l'âme amateurs notamment
enfin tout le monde cherche fait des
films de vacances en couleurs lors je
pense que la couleur et une évolution
normale
donc je crois un très grand
développement de la couleur à très
grands développements locaux leur encore
faut-il si vous voulez que les prix les
prix soient convenables ça allait
acheter un poste alors pas dans
l'immédiat trop cher
pour l'instant j'en viens depuis une
dizaine d'années en noir et blanc puis
soit amorti de plus la vie animale déjà
à faire la télévision de shell en noir
alors que la couleur c'est sûr de
l'enfant pour l'instant on va les moyens
je ne payerai vous avez acheté un poste
alors je pense se penche et encore un
petit peu oui
alors allez vous acheter un poste pas
tout de suite aimé ça viendra
[Musique]
pour produire en série des récepteurs
couleurs les constructeurs français ont
dû livrer une véritable course contre la
montre
[Musique]
en moins d'un an ils ont installé des
chaînes de production un peu partout en
france pour pouvoir gagner la bataille
de la couleur arme principale de cette
bataille
le tube cathodique différence
fondamentale entre noir et blanc et
couleur bien sûr il ya beaucoup de
différences
mais avant d'en arriver à la plaie et
vous est intéressant de passer
rapidement en revue l'évolution des pubs
pour la télévision depuis les 20
dernières années
depuis le premier tube rond de 1947
jusqu'au tubes actuels en voyant que les
tubes ont changé d'abord de forme ils
sont devenus rectangulaire ils ont
changé également de profondeur de façon
à permettre la réalisation de récepteurs
moins encombrant et nous arrivons ainsi
à au dernier né de la part des
productions françaises le tube couleurs
les deux fabricants français ont décidé
d'assurer dès 1967
la mise en route d'une production sur le
système des tubes dit à masquer perforé
la seule à être réalisable
industriellement aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
oh
et
cyril rool la fabrication en série des
fausses couleurs vous êtes exposés des
problèmes différents la fabrication des
postes couleur au noir et blanc
nous avions des différences absolument
fondamental car fabriquer des
téléviseurs en couleurs
c'était pratiquement fabriquer 3
télévisée en scène mais vous voyez que
ce retrait n'a été totalement maîtrisé
et la visite que nous faisons
aujourd'hui la chute la chaîne de
fabrication qui vous et montrez vous
pour suffisamment que nous sommes dès le
début de septembre à mai à offrir au
public des téléviseurs actuellement
fabriqué en série
le prix moyen d'un récepteur fuller
actuellement est de 5000 francs ne
concerne pas que ces prix élevés vont
freiner le développement de la
télévision en couleurs eh bien il est
évident qu'au départ la télévision
couleur s'adressera aux couches aisées
de la population
cela dit il faut que vous sachiez que la
france étant le promoteur
d'un système international couleurs
l'industrie française se devait de
donner aux téléspectateurs français
une image d'une exceptionnelle qualité
elles se devaient de plus de donner à
ses téléspectateurs sur un même appareil
couleurs l'ensemble des émissions 819
ligne et 625 ligne couleur et noir et
blanc et lee a réussi et c'est au départ
une technique chère
il faut tenir compte également en france
des conditions fiscales dont le public
connaît bien les incidences de taux de
la tva est aussi l'ensemble des marges
de commercialisation qui vont de lusine
de l'industriel à la vitrine du
revendeur
j'ai de la loi vous êtes commerçant vous
représentez tout le commerce de détail
radio télévision à trois semaines du
lancement la chaîne couleurs comment se
présente le marché ce qu'il ya beaucoup
de commandes il ya surtout beaucoup de
personnes intéressées par la télévision
couleur que je ne pense pas qu
actuellement ils viennent ornements de
commande et pour quelles raisons d'après
vous est ce que c'est une raison de prix
essentiellement l'une des raisons
essentielles et évidemment le prix
relativement élevé est ce que justement
le commerçant est peut-être un peu
fautif
cette affaire au absolument pas pour la
raison suivante vous avez deux
catégories de prix dans la production
actuelle certains fabricants ont choisi
les prix conseillés et le concède à ce
moment là quelque chose comme 25 % en or
que la plupart des grandes banques
auront choisi le prix de cession net du
fabricant bon vendeur laissant ce
dernier le soin de déterminer le prix de
détail
or les prix suggérés par ces mêmes
fabricants nous laisse environ 20% ce
qui est insuffisant ce qui représente
par exemple pour un poste de type valeur
de 5000 francs qui vont du 5000 fonds
publics
ce large de 1000 francs au cela
représente plus de fonds effectivement
et 20% sont insuffisants si l'on tient
compte que la marge moyenne des frais
généraux dans nos entreprises
représentent environ 25 ans elle ya
également un autre problème important
est ce que le commerce de détail s'est
préparé un dépannage des postes couleurs
depuis plusieurs mois en collaboration
avec le rtf les symboles qui ont la
formation professionnelle des adultes
nous avons effectivement appelé des
milliers de professionnels qui ont
répondu ailleurs positivement pour
renforcer leurs connaissances techniques
et ils ont même été jusqu'à faire des
investissements de plusieurs millions
d'appareils de mesure après nous en
faire face voilà maintenant ce qui
imposera
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de
différences entre un téléviseur noir et
blanc et un téléviseur couleur c'est
évident il ya une très grosse différence
surtout au point de vue complexité de
l'appareil n'ont pas complexité pour les
réglages l usage des usagers pour
l'installateur
alors est ce que le téléspectateur
pourra lui même faire quelques réglages
et bien il aura très peu de réglages à
faire dans la télé couleur disparaît
creusement les mêmes que sur un
téléviseur noir et blanc c'est à dire
c'est et boutons qui sont à sa
disposition
mais évidemment pour l'installateur
c'était votre histoire
alors là vous avez une série de boutons
à l'intérieur d'une petite partie caché
qu'il faut porter une trentaine de
moutons qui est obligatoirement à régler
à la mise en relation des appareils et
que le téléspectateur ne doit absolument
changer en général comment convertir ce
qu'il préparait à l'avènement de la
couleur sur le plan des programmes
c'était presque plus délicat dans la
mesure où je crois vraiment que la
couleur ajoute une dimension nouvelle
rémission est là aussi l'effort est
considérable puisque depuis plus d'un an
les réalisateurs s'attaquent à ce
problème de la couleur lors le public va
être juge et ce matin encore je voyais
l'une des nombreuses émissions que nous
avons préparée dans cette perspective en
me rendant compte de tout ce que cela
implique de difficultés c'est un film
sur tollet delgreco et bien que le
public a des références dans cette
affaire c'est ce que sont les couleurs
du greco c'est ce que sont les couleurs
d'une ville comme solène et nous ne
pouvons pas nous permettre de lui donner
des images qui soit en deçà de ses
couleurs du greco au delà aux
différentes et pas davantage des
couleurs de tollens cela donne la
difficulté des problèmes que nous avons
à résoudre qui est beaucoup plus
considérable puis du noir et du blanc
mais je crois que de ce qui a été fait
de l'expérience accumulée par le maire
de celle que dont nous avons bénéficié
du fait que d'autres ont commencé à
gauche par spécialement de génériques
nous avons là un un ensemble de
ference d'expérience qui nous
permettront je crois en commençant le
1er octobre de donner au public une
couleur intéressante belle et qui
ajoutera une dimension supplémentaire au
plaisir qu'il éprouve regarder la
télévision
mais ce lancement de télévision couleur
a dû exiger de gros efforts sur le plan
financier
oui mais la rtf dans le passé avec lui à
connaître les efforts semblables
lorsqu'il s'est agi de lancer la
télévision et ce moment là le lancement
a été supporté au fond parce qu'ils ne
détenaient que la radiodiffusion sommes
aujourd'hui un petit peu en présence
d'un phénomène à l'homme ce que je puis
dire c'est que grâce à un ensemble de
mesures qui ont été prises aussi bien au
sein de fisc à l'échelon du gouvernement
la garantie est donné que ce
développement de la couleur ne se fera
pas au détriment de ceux qui assurent
aujourd'hui pour l'essentiel les
ressources de l'office c'est à dire les
détenteurs d'appareils de radiodiffusion
et des détenteurs d'appareils de
télévision en noir et blanc en noir et
blanc
je crois pouvoir dire que le budget de
l'année prochaine de ce qu'il se
présente laissera intactes les chances
les possibilités des noir et blanc et
que mon dieu les perspectives de
l'office de ce point de vue ne va pas
décevoir son public ici de la couleur ni
celui du noir et blanc la meilleure
couleur que vous pourrez voir le mois
prochain
c'est en effet à partir du 1er octobre
que le rtf diffusera 12 heures de
programmes couleur par semaine y compris
les actualités télévisées
en attendant voici en noir et blanc un
extrait du couple amoureux de jean
christophe averty
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le bas
m
et voici la couleur au jour fixé et à
l'heure dite madame mademoiselle
monsieur vous qui maintenant nous voyez
tels que nous sommes vous cesserez très
vite je ne sais bien d'être sensible à
la magie de la chose et vous trouverez
bientôt tout à fait naturel de voir la
vie avec ses couleurs envahir vos écrans
je voudrais tout de même vous demander
au moins en ce premier jour de
considérer qu'il s'agit là d'un tour de
force technique et d'une petite
révolution
je voudrais donc d'abord remercier ceux
qui ont rendu possible cette mutation
décisive dans l'histoire de notre
télévision d'abord l'inventeur monsieur
henri de france inventeur du procédé
français ccam
puis tous eu un gène year techniciens
ouvriers qui ont contribué à la mise au
point technique et industriel de cette
invention
puis les industriels français qui ont
réussi à mettre sur le marché à la date
convenue leurs premiers récepteurs et
cela n'a pas été facile je sais et enfin
bien entendu la ftf représenter autour
de moi qui depuis des années
préparer ce rendez vous ce rendez vous
il a fallu pour le tenir beaucoup
d'efforts à tous et encore une fois je
les en remercie
je sais bien que pour l'instant nos
images en couleurs ne sont accessibles
qu'à quelques privilégiés et qu'elles
ont un certain caractère confidentiel
encore mais je veux espérer que
l'engouement du public la qualité des
programmes penaud ftf vous proposera
et aussi le désir qu'a le gouvernement
de faire en sorte que la télévision
couleur soit un phénomène populaire
modifieront profondément les conditions
du marché et rendront accessible la
télévision en couleur au plus grand
nombre des français avant de passer la
parole à monsieur jacques bernard dupont
directeur général de l'oncf
je voudrais que même présenté deux
brèves remarques
la première c'est que la télévision en
couleurs c'est une révolution technique
mais aussi une révolution dans notre
manière de devoir c'est à dire de penser
et de sentir
c'est une révolution artistique
également car la couleur ce n'est pas le
noir et le blanc
polhenri y est c'est quelque chose de
nouveau et de différent et cela va poser
aux artistes aux réalisateurs de la ftf
aussi bien qu'aux techniciens des
problèmes nouveaux et difficiles
encore une fois c'est une opération
difficile que nous entreprenons ici ma
deuxième remarque se doublera d'un voeu
il est bon de constater que l'image la
plus belle plus chatoyant climat en
couleurs est en même temps la plus frais
et la plus proche de la vie qui est en
couleur c'est là un symbole assez
encourageant pour un ministre de
l'information et tour un gouvernement
je veux donc souhaité du fond du coeur
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs que
votre vie quotidienne soit de plus en
plus vrai de plus en plus belle est de
plus en plus colorés des pour le reste à
vous de juger
comme le disait léonard-de-vinci l'oeil
se trompent moins que l'esprit
nous aurions souhaité bien sûr d'être
jugé aujourd'hui précisément par le plus
grand nombre
nous savons que pour des raisons
parfaitement compréhensible cela ne peut
pas être le cas mais nous avons fait un
gros effort pour que ce programme
inaugural puissent être suivis par le
plus de téléspectateurs possible ainsi
aujourd'hui à la maison de l'eau arte
est fait pour tous les jours qui vont
suivre des récepteurs dans couleurs sont
à votre disposition pour suivre les
programmes couleurs de l'office de même
aujourd'hui dans toutes les stations de
loire tf en province
des démonstrations sont organisées pour
que vous puissiez voir la qualité des
programmes couleurs qui vous sont
proposés notre voeu reste tout de même
celui que vous puissiez très vite
recevoir chez vous ces programmes les
recevoir dans les meilleures conditions
et monsieur mercier directeur de
l'équipement des exploitations vous dira
peut-être les conditions dans lesquelles
une telle réception est possible bien
sûr la télévision en couleurs c'est
certainement beaucoup plus complexe que
la télévision en noir et blanc aussi
bien pour nous ce n'est pas nous
techniciens ont ce jour ou quittent le
secret du laboratoire allait s'y
reporter les grecs c'est l'usagé ce
n'est pas un commencement c'est un
aboutissement
l'aboutissement d'une très longue
période de préparation très minutieuse
nous avons essayé précisément de nous
mettre dans les conditions les
meilleures pour que précisément au
moment où chrome os ce service régulier
nous puissions garantir à l'usagé des
signaux qui souhaitent aussi correct que
possible je passe sur la mutation des
sionistes on nous avait parlé en ce qui
concerne l'équipement la transformation
de nos matériels mais ceci si vous
laissez notre affaire maintenant il
s'agit que chaque jour nous puissions
livrer ses signaux comme je le disais
tout à l'heure dans leur perfection et
cela je pense que nous sommes prêts
encore faut-il que ces signaux soit
traduit également dans d'autres bonnes
conditions chez le récepteur de visage
et est là aussi j'ai parfaite confiance
dans l'expérience que nous avons eu une
et soir monsieur dupont
depuis que
que moi de certains récepteurs qui nous
ont été mis à notre disposition on a pu
se rendre compte que les réglages
étaient parfaitement stable
encore faut-il que ces réglages soit
fait est que ces réglages tienne c'est à
dire que l'usager n'aura prendre
quelques précautions
il ne pourra pas modifier l'emplacement
du récepteur réglé ils ont à sa
convenance et sans prendre dix ans la
précaution de faire revoir les réglages
de ce récepteur il devra prendre
quelques précautions concernant
l'éclairage ambiant du tube par exemple
mais avec ses précautions
je pense que une main d'un bout à
l'autre de la chaîne depuis la caméra
jusque ses usagers nous sommes prêts
pour une exploitation quotidienne de la
couleur reste maintenant les programmes
sont désormais la responsabilité
les miniers zini direct à la télévision
ce rendez vous d'aujourd'hui est le
résultat d'un tour de force technique
des services de leur tf1 ne faut jamais
oublier de les remercier mais la parole
appartient désormais à ceux qui sont
chargés de donner à la télévision tout
son sens c'est à dire d'en faire le
véhicule des moyens d'information de
culture d'enrichissement sous toutes
leurs formes s'adressant au plus grand
nombre à ce travail la direction des
télévisions s'est préparée elle aussi
depuis longtemps et elle présente ses
premiers deux premiers fruits de ses
efforts aujourd'hui mais elle n'oublie
pas que ce programme en couleurs avec
tous l'enrichissement que la couleur lui
apporte ce programme n'est vu en
couleurs que par un petit nombre et
qu'il faudra un certain nombre de mois
sinon m
pour que la couleur devienne un
phénomène véritablement populaire
implanté dans tout le pays
c'est pourquoi il convient de rassurer
dès aujourd'hui et téléspectateurs
ancien est habituel de la rtf
il rompt ils recevront les mêmes
programmes et la qualité de ses
programmes ne sera pas pour eux atteinte
il faut comme je viens de dire monsieur
mise informations que la couleur apporte
au plus grand nombre de français le
maximum d'enrichissement et la direction
de la télévision
si on pleurera
[Musique]